every time you turn on the news some new
country is starting some war
with another arab country everybody's
fighting the arabs and nobody's beating
them you know what that means stop
[ __ ] with the arabs
here's why nobody's beating them because
you can't intimidate them
if you can't intimidate somebody even a
little bit you can't beat them
like right before the u.s went to war
with iraq they warned iraq
we're going to come there and we're
going to attack you
and iraq went okay
even the us was like i don't think he
understood
i'm gonna i'm gonna try it again we're
gonna come to your country
and attack you
no problem no problem
it's okay he wants to come let them come
ya la come yella come on let's go
the us was like i think we got to break
it down for this guy
we are going to come to your country
and kill you
oh yeah you kill me
[ __ ] you
and kill me
[Applause]
you can't beat people with those kinds
of odds that's like getting into a fight
with somebody like you i'ma kick the
[ __ ] out of you yeah [ __ ] you i'll kick
the [ __ ] out of myself
now what do you do just stand around and
wait you done yet no
i still got some ass left
i gotta thank y'all personally because
after september 11th you all took all
the pressure off us
i'm telling you arabs are the new [ __ ]
i ain't playing
i get on a plane now white people y'all
be happy to see us
hey come here man sit next to me bro
here hold my daughter if it goes down
are you ready did you bring your [ __ ]
it's me and you bro
you got to watch out for those guys
they're scared
i like arab people but you know what's
funny to me as arab men young arab men
cause their [ __ ] know their
position too they got a lot of money you
know their [ __ ] don't be having
no verbal game
but they don't need it they'd be in a
club and be just rude to a woman oh what
are you doing what is your name come
here talk to me
as soon as you don't give no action
ladies that's when i get mad i don't
need from you this but
that that please don't please
you don't tell me you don't want to [ __ ]
with me please [ __ ] please
i have a lot of money i own missile i
don't need from you but
please
i am not terrorist but um watch out
please don't [ __ ] with me this way [ __ ]
please
you know who else would be bold too as
african men they're [ __ ] boy
they don't give a [ __ ]
because my best friend is from west
africa man and african dudes are hostile
ladies if you don't get them no action
they'll cuss you out immediately
they be in the club watching you what
are you doing here what is your name
come talk to me
what do you mean you don't want to [ __ ]
with me [ __ ] get from here i don't need
you
you think you can talk this way with me
don't need to [ __ ] around
i want to buy you the drink you come
here all the [ __ ] you get from here
who does this [ __ ] think she should
talk to me like this i don't give a [ __ ]
[Music]
you got to be easy with women man you
got to you know because black people you
know we got game naturally brothers we
know how to talk to them
you know we know how to just say that
[ __ ] sometimes i'm african dudes they
don't know what to say they just so
angry what's what do you call yourself
what is your name you talk to me
you say i'm talking to you in the front
row you don't want to talk to me [ __ ]
you
get up and you'll ask me later
i think that's some cool [ __ ] of accent
man if you got a nice accent you can get
away with a lot of [ __ ]
because you be in the club and say
something foul to a woman in an american
accent she might slap the [ __ ] at you
like excuse me baby i don't mean to
bother you but you got a fat ass i'd
love to take you home [ __ ] this [ __ ] at
you
[ __ ] english accent that just
rolled off the tongue a lot smoother
like
excuse me i don't mean to bother you but
i'd really love to take you home and
[ __ ] your dog yourself a little bit yeah
i mean
[ __ ] where you from this [ __ ] is
sexy
oh my god say something else
ladies y'all laughing some of the fellas
might try that on the way home man
you have a good time with your sundaes
can you give me a little bit of hair
just a little bit
i don't want much just a little bit of
brains you know what i mean
underrated arabs oh god
what no i mean it's not bad that they're
yeah i don't know where it's going i
just judged it by you really did it
arabs well i mean hey you know what i
did ain't that bad
exactly that's how you heard it but
that's how you heard it
that's not how i heard it that's how i
heard it i was like oh great this would
be something complimentary considering
the beef we've been having i mean since
since 9 11. this is this is some
positive i like let's bring people
together
all right hey hey there red uh i am a 21
year old guy from saudi arabia
um wish to know if you plan to include
us in your next tour
our government pays good money for
entertainment well what are the
parameters
i just want to make sure i ain't going
over there and all of a sudden i say
something
you know the wrong [ __ ] thing and
then i get in trouble i
i don't need that what country was i
in where you i think was singapore where
i was just going like oh [ __ ] man
you know you know you spit gum out on
the street they [ __ ] beat the [ __ ]
out of you with a goddamn
[ __ ] nearest tree or something um
he says anyways in the last five years
or so i watched a considerable amount of
movies and tv shows and came to notice
that there's a stereotype
you westerners you westerns have about
us
which is that we're either illiterate
[ __ ] who live in the desert
tending our camels and thinking about
blowing your country
blowing up your country not blowing your
country or
or that we're buried in money and don't
have any problems
dude i gotta be honest with you the
second you said you were from saudi
arabia i just pictured somebody
vacationing in london
shipping his cars in one car and in one
plane and himself in his private jet
right yeah no there is like definitely
that stereotype of like the saudi prince
that's like yeah spending money
but i never i never thought the
illiterate thing though yeah no i never
thought that but yeah you definitely
have this idea of
yeah oh i and i have the feeling that if
i go over to the middle east
as an american that
we just we just had so many [ __ ] you
know not good back and forths over there
that i'm gonna get the [ __ ] ass
kicking that they want to give
our last three [ __ ] presidents um
anyway uh and i want to squash the
stereotype by saying that we live our
lives just like you
i myself come from a middle-class family
and i study energy engineering
this is such a great [ __ ] email i'm
glad this came in
i listened to western music and i'm
familiar with the bands and love the
beatles in zeppelin
i watched the nba and even like the
celtics ah this [ __ ] guy is great
the sellies my friends and i hang out in
cafes or whatever
and we try to pick up chicks of course
the only difference between us is that
you probably do these activities while
drinking alcohol
uh when we drink drink coffee or any
kind of soda
and that i have hair and you don't
please continue consider touring here
wouldn't miss it go [ __ ] yourself well
you know what i mean
that is a great email that's really cool
yeah all right that is that did make me
think
didn't we have that experience in london
not of like
saudis specifically or anything like
that but wasn't there something when we
were in london one time and there was a
bunch of cars like really
luxury cars that were just going down
this one main drain oh no it was
hilarious
those were the princess the princes were
over there what's going on
yeah yeah yeah and they were just kind
of it was this whole
parade was like a display of beautiful
luxury vehicles that were just
okay you want to know what really
happened it was a bunch of rich
princes in in ferraris and lamborghinis
driving like in stop and go traffic just
revving the engines
they're loud as [ __ ] really getting
anywhere and they had all these
like wraps on on the cars and [ __ ]
and i was my favorite i was walking up
the street
and as they were revving the engine like
loud as [ __ ]
this english woman just goes ah
stop it
[Laughter]
it was hilarious the old british bitty
yeah they were showing off
i believe i believe your people call it
stuntin
um all right now i'm in trouble
i should have said it i said it with the
next ghost dad reference
ghost dad i mean that is [ __ ] up
there
[Music]
so
[Music]
you